und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend lange hatte die union keinen
kanzlerkandidaten seit heute mittag hat
sie 2 die wollen die frage bleibt ob sie
einen hat der es auch kann und ob der
ist dann auch wird der darf geklärt ist
heute abend erstmal nur die frage ob es
wirklich will
er will alles andere bleibt offen
angeblich nicht mehr lang vor dem
gespräch mit markus söder
der bericht von venedig es gibt diesen
einen moment in der pressekonferenz
da kann sich armin laschet das lachen
und das glucksen kaum verkneifen
vielleicht weil seine ohren worte hören
die seine erfahrung kaum zu glauben
vermag am inn hat in einem interview
gesagt wir beide schätzen und
durchschauen uns ich glaube so kann man
es auch sagen dann wirklich ein gutes
miteinander und wir werden das auch egal
wieder an die konstellation ist jeden
fall ich endlich das für mich sagen er
zusammen schultern
was zu beweisen ist denn mit heute ist
die katze aus dem sack habe dann das für
mich selber auch noch mal überlegt und
gewogen und habe dann eben meine
bereitschaft heute erklärt im
zuständigen gremium nämlich bei der
fraktion nicht durch ein interview
sondern im zuständigen gremium gesagt
dass ich bereit bin zu kandidieren mich
dieser verantwortung zu stellen
markus söder und ich haben vor dem
heutigen tag ein langes gespräch
miteinander geführt
wir haben unsere bereitschaft erklärt
für die kanzlerkandidatur anzutreten
markus söder hat mit der k frage lange
gespielt sie ironisiert das tier
ausgewichen das letzte mal heute morgen
als er zu einer fraktionsklausur am
reichstag ankommt damit ist die frage
geschichte und die antwort poesie auf
wartezeiten aber wie gesagt ja mal ein
beispiel für lebenskünstler sagen wir
mal das immer so markus söder und die
medien traube wer in der politik was
werden will braucht macht wer besser
sein will als andere braucht mehr macht
titel die ministerpräsident oder
parteichef nutzen
das weiß auch armin laschet ja nimmt am
morgen den seiteneingang seit dem
gespräch mit söder gestern fräst sich
laschet hinter den kulissen mit anrufen
durch seine partei denn das wird nach
der fraktionsklausur die heute keine
rolle mehr spielte und die beide
fraktionschefs zu statisten erklärt beim
gemeinsamen auftritt deutlich laschet
hofft auf die macht seiner cdu oder
setzt auf die macht des öffentlichen
eindrucks hat in einem der interviews
letzten gesagt und das fand ich wichtig
und auch beeindruckend es soll dann am
ende derjenige der kanzlerkandidat sein
der die besten wahlchancen für unsere
gemeinsame idee hat die bereitschaft von
zweien liegt auf dem tisch
die aufgabenstellung liegt auch auf dem
tisch und jetzt werden wir diese
beratung morgen zunächst in der cdu und
dann in der csu erleben
es ist für beide wichtig für armin und
mich für uns beide dass wir die
entscheidung nicht auf biegen und
brechen fällen wie es nun weitergeht ist
völlig offen es gibt termine
parteigremien telefonschalten aber einen
plan hat die union nicht damit
hinterlassen markus söder und armin
laschet vor allem das publikum in ihrer
eigenen partei überrascht bis schockiert
heute abend auch sprachlos
niemand will öffentlich kommentieren was
nun losgebrochen ist ein machtkampf in
der union
es wird gewinner verlierer und verletzte
geben
guten abend herr söder
schönen guten abend ich bin nicht ganz
sicher ob ich das verstanden habe wenn
ich es richtig verstanden habe dann ist
es so sie werden kanzlerkandidat nur
dann wenn die cdu ihren häuptling fallen
lässt und ruft markus söder kommen und
macht das für uns korrekt
nein wir haben verantwortung beide
parteivorsitzenden eine große
verantwortung und schwerer zeit
die lage ist sehr ernst für die union
bis in fünf monate vor der wahl sinkende
umfragewerte
es macht sich etwas wechselstimmung
breit und besiegen muss man überlegen
was ist die bestmöglichste lösung für
diese schwierigeren herausfordernde wahl
ich habe mir zu meiner lebensplanung
gezählt aber habe nach unzähligen
anfragen wünschen aus der bevölkerung
natürlich auch nach dem
stand der chancen über die umfragen
einfach gemeinsam mit armin laschet lang
beraten und wir haben beide festgestellt
einem freundschaftlichen gespräch dass
wir beide bereit sind diese
verantwortung anzunehmen und dass wir
jetzt schauen müssen wie es weitergeht
wer hat insgesamt die besten chancen und
klar als vorsitzender der csu ist man
vorsitzer der kleineren gemeinschaft
kleineren partei und es kann überhaupt
nur gehen wenn man breit getragen wird
von der cdu von parteien fraktionen den
mitgliedern und das ist der sachstand
jetzt entscheidet dann letztlich
zunächst mal die cdu wie sie mit dieser
situation umgeht und dann haben wir
gemeinsam beraten was das
gemeinschaftliche ergebnisses nun haben
sie das alles sehr schön gesagt aber
eine frage ist noch nicht beantwortet
tatsächlich aber so habe ich jetzt
verstanden die cdu muss ihren häuptling
fallen lassen und den häuptling söder
aus münchen rufen
sonst werden sie nicht kanzlerkandidat
das stimmt ja das würde rein
arithmetisch nicht gehen das ist ja in
der geschichte immer so gewesen
die csu kann und will hersteller zwingen
es kommt auch nicht darauf an auf biegen
und brechen
aber so wie sie es in turnieren mit dem
fallenlassen glaube ich es der falsche
ansatz denn es geht hier um
verantwortung
es geht verantwortung für mich selbst
man könnte sich sehr leicht machen also
schwere verantwortung gern aus dem weg
gehen das würde ich nicht tun
also ich wäre bereit mich dieser
verantwortung zu stellen aber eben nur
dann wenn es in beiden parteien auf eine
breite unterstützung stößt und wenn auch
das getragen da denn ein solcher
wahlkampf in diesen zeiten
den muss man ja mit maximalen einsatz
mit größtmöglicher geschlossenheit gehen
und diese geschlossenheit herzustellen
es lässt sich die aufgabe von uns beiden
und ich bin sicher das wird uns auch
gelingen
nun wenn sie immer mal wieder die
umfragen aber die sollen ja nicht der
einzige maßstab sein die frage mich was
sonst der maßstab sein soll
denn in der sache versichern sie beide
sind sie fast deckungsgleich da gibt es
keine unterschiede wonach soll denn die
fraktion oder das präsidium der partei
morgen entscheiden wenn nicht nach dem
umfragen ja meist muss man zunächst
einmal beurteilen und spielen unfall
schon natürlich eine rolle welche
perspektiven man sieht auch in einem
wahlkampf und da gibt es auch andere
strategische fragen die man durchaus
wegen und beachten kann ich will nicht
immer nur auf die umfragen verweisen
weil also jetzt schon am start auf dem
produkt tragen wo es einmal ein
derjenige redet der gerade vorne liegt
und sie liegen deutlich
was spricht denn für eine andere lösung
wenn sie inhaltlich die gleiche richtung
haben aber nur die umfragen sprechen
eindeutig für sie dann ist doch die
entscheidungen konnte schon gefahren ja
es gibt schon unterschiedliche akzente
auch die wir beide haben aber das sind
keine unüberbrückbaren die am ende doch
zu einem gemeinsamen programm kommen
werden
ich sitze deutlich mehr auf den bereich
versöhnung wirtschaft und umwelt mit
klimaschutz armin laschet hat andere
aktien aber beides zusammen wäre dann
doch ohnehin das programm das wir haben
übrigens gegenüber anderen parteien die
sehr wenig anzubieten
wir haben heute pöbel truppe von der afg
erlebt wir haben grüne ohne
regierungserfahrung jedenfalls von den
beiden kandidaten jedenfalls keine
größere regierungserfahrung die da
anstehen das ist schon finde ich ein
ganz großer unterschied aber jetzt muss
die union einfach für sich selber
entscheiden was der richtige weg ist ich
mache ein angebot
ich mache ein angebot ich will nichts
erzwingen im so wie es vielleicht die
csu früher gern gemacht hat sehr
lautstark auftretend erzwingen sondern
ein angebot für eine grenze lässt ersten
aber sie wollte es letztlich sonders
elegante weise werden das wäre noch
elegant ist immer besser als anders
erklärte das wissen sie sich selbst und
deswegen ist es glaube ich auch fair ist
ein fairer prozess den wir machen ein
ehrlicher prozess er ist auch übrigens
sehr transparent er ist einladend
gesehen und jetzt haben wir ja eine
woche oder zehn tage spätestens ich
denke es ist aber in dieser woche sogar
möglich eine entscheidung
gemeinschaftlich zu treffen
aus verantwortung heraus es geht um
deutschland es geht um die wichtigste
aufgabe überhaupt und wenn es um
deutschland geht dann geht es auch sehr
stark um europa das sind geht es da
nicht um die frage jetzt mal zwischen
zwei leuten ist einfach im hinterzimmer
aus zu kugeln sondern auf eine breitere
basis zu stellen das tun wir beide und
das kann ich auch ganz sicher sagen dass
wir beide freundschaftlich verbunden
sind und in jedem fall bleiben das geht
ja auch nicht um persönliche karrieren
ambitionen sondern es geht um die
verantwortung für viele viele menschen
in unserem land nun ist er die situation
der pandemie im moment eine der größten
krisen in unserer erinnerung
solche situationen verlangen einen
bestimmten politikertypus den macher typ
das sind sie aber wenn das thema nicht
völlig vergeigt wird dann ist die
situation im august/september ja
hoffentlich eine völlig andere und ein
anderer politiker typ vielleicht eher
ein armin laschet zu
samen bringer und versöhner wäre dann
der richtige ist es dann überhaupt klug
die sache jetzt schon zu entscheiden
nun das kann man so das so sehen aber
ich glaube es ist auch notwendig dass
man nicht nur den parteien zu den
menschen jetzt auch klar macht wer tritt
an wer steht für die handschrift der
union und wer repräsentiert auch die
große gemeinschaft von cdu csu
das können wir beide und das werden wir
auch zusammen tun jeder in seiner
verantwortung
egal wer jetzt anfange steht weil eines
ist klar die beiden parteivorsitzenden
müssen auch nach dieser persönlichen
entscheidung am ende gemeinschaftlich
eng zusammenarbeiten wir sind nicht die
kohl und strauß die in einer jahrelangen
fehde miteinander dann am ende sich
entwickelt haben sondern wir müssen und
wir werden am ende auch gemeinsam
zusammenarbeiten danke also da so viel
zu diesem punkt vor einer guten stunde
in einem gespräch auf dass wir gleich
zurück kommen das muss heute auch
gesprochen werden über die grundstücke
der änderung der pandemie politik ein
bundesgesetz ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz soll die
regierungen der länder dazu bringen
selbst gefasste beschlüsse die notbremse
auch tatsächlich umzusetzen
die vereinigung der intensiv medizin hat
daten erhoben die bestätigen wie
katastrophal die entwicklung zurzeit
läuft wir haben gute zeit punkte schon
verpasst so glimpflich wäre es
ausgegangen wenn lang vor ostern ein
erster shutdown bekommen hätte damit die
intelligenten unter 100 bleiben
das ist nicht passiert wir sind bei 130
min die inzidenz mal bei 200 wie kann
auch ein shutdown einen viel schlimmeren
verlauf nicht mehr aufhalten
es ist einfach zu viel zeit vergangen
die spitze von 7.000 intensivpatienten
anfang mai mehr als je zuvor ist kaum
mehr aufzuhalten weil die welle auch
nach einem shutter und erstmal 14 bis 17
tage einfach weiterläuft die
erkundigungen von dalian tag haben ein
klares ergebnis gehandelt werden muss
jetzt
es sind die pragmatischen entscheidungen
der politik die es dieser tage braucht
verbindliche entscheidungen rasch die
sie hier dringend brauchen
die dritte welle
ab denn die kliniken seit 10 märz hat
sich die zahl der intensivpatienten mit
19 mehr als verdoppelt deswegen können
wir nur nochmals an ihrer politik
appellieren jetzt schnell zu handeln
damit wir schnell mit den
infektionszahlen unterkommen hoffnung
gibt die notbremse die nun
bundeseinheitlich und verbindlich gelten
soll so der plan der bundesregierung mit
gleich mehreren maßnahmen für landkreise
mit einer sieben tage incidents von mehr
als 100 an drei aufeinanderfolgenden
tagen erlaubt sind dann unter anderem
nur noch private treffen eines
haushaltes mit einer weiteren person und
von maximal fünf personen nächtliche
ausgangsbedingungen von 21 bis 5 uhr mit
nur wenigen ausnahmen für schüler/innen
schlägt der bund eine testpflicht vor
und soll bei hohen infektionszahlen
rechtsverordnungen erlassen dürfen
derzeit wären in etwa der hälfte aller
landkreise öffnungen damit verboten doch
die hoffnung auf eine rasche umsetzung
wird gedämpft was die frage der
ausgangssperren angeht das geht so nicht
das ist ein dermaßen massiver eingriff
in die grund und freiheitsrechte
das kann man nicht einmal in europas so
machen dafür muss lange nachgedacht
werden lange diskutiert werden ich finde
nicht richtig was im moment in diesem
gesetz steht weil die arbeitswelt nach
wie vor verschont wird und weil es nach
wie vor nicht praktikabel ist vor allem
für familien mit kindern hier braucht es
dringend änderungen wir wollen nicht
dass durch die kalte küche der
föderalismus ausgehebelt wird die länder
können das eigenverantwortlich haben sie
doch bis jetzt gekannt und nach der
gescheiterten oster ruhe sollte es nicht
schon wieder ein mit heißer nadel
gestrickt das gesetz geben um die
notbremse im eilverfahren beschließen zu
können bräuchte es im bundestag eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und die zustimmung
im bundesrat bundesfinanzminister scholz
zerstreut am abend zweifel die
spd-regierten länder würden nicht
geschlossen hinter dem entwurf stehen
ich hatte unmittelbar bevor ich zu ihnen
gekommen bin ein gespräch mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der spd und sie
stehen alle hinter diesem vorgehen
werden das auch unterstützen es wird
ordentliche beratung geben aber der weg
ist klar und von allen getragen
ein weg der dauert und zeit kostet
wertvolle zeit
jede politische entscheidung die jetzt
kommt und dazu führt dass die
infektionszahlen hoffentlich fallen
werden kommt auf der intensivstation
etwa zwei wochen später an das heißt wir
sind sowieso damit konfrontiert dass wir
mindestens für zwei wochen noch ein
anstieg der patientenzahl sehen werden
bedeutet jeder tag den wir jetzt
verlieren bedeutet für uns wieder noch
mehr patienten mehr patienten weniger
betten und noch weniger personal und ein
gesundheitssystem das noch immer auf
pragmatische lösungen aus berlin hofft
lassen sie uns noch über das thema
corona bekämpfung sprechen
wir stehen jetzt vor der notwendigkeit
offenbar noch eine woche vielleicht
sogar länger einen gesetzgebungsprozess
durchzuziehen in einer situation wo wir
gerade gesehen haben die hütte wirklich
brennt und das ist nur deshalb notwendig
weil die ministerpräsidenten offenbar
nicht in der lage waren ohne erwachsene
aufsicht ihre eigenen beschlüsse
umzusetzen das ist doch der wahre grund
für diese gesetzesänderung ist das nicht
ein ziemlich vernichtendes urteil über
die arbeit der ministerpräsident nein
das finde ich nichts kann man nicht so
einfach sagen wenn man es etwas böse
formulieren will dann kann man immer
etwas negatives finde ich glaub nicht
ich habe vor über einem jahr als die
erste welle abgeklungen war übrigens
genau diese these vertreten
ich habe diese these vertreten dass eine
pandemie die sich nicht an landesgrenzen
oder landkreisgrenzen nicht mal
nationale grenzen hält
dass die natürlich auch ein
einheitliches nationales vorgehen
aufforderten was aber das wurde ja durch
den raum präsidentenkonferenz angestrebt
ein einheitliches verhalten haben
einheitlich und nein so einfach kann man
sich machen aber ich glaube sie haben in
der tat recht
es wurde oft auch immer wieder
unterschiedlich interpretiert weil die
beschlüsse auch manche interpretation
zugelassen haben und das sind glaube ich
das ist jetzt so viel besseres als ich
unterstütze bisher
ich hoffe auch dass die opposition in
berlin nicht blockiert so dass das
verfahren schnell geschehen kann kann
nämlich schon in dieser woche das gesetz
beschlossen werden
es liegt also an der opposition im
bundestag ob sie's blockieren oder nicht
ich hoffe auch sehr dass die spd in der
bundesregierung nicht weiter blockiert
wie in den letzten wochen
öfter sondern genauso mit an einem
strang zieht dann kann man das schnell
beschließen und dann haben eine klare
linie und ich unterstütze den kurs der
bundeskanzlerin zu 100 prozent
und sie sind sicher dass das bis ende
der woche klappt ja mit allen anderen
parteien ja schon kontakt gehabt
ich bin hoffnungsvoll und jetzt liegt
wie gesagt an der opposition ob sie das
verfahren beschleunigt in der sache wird
sicherlich kommen
ob in dieser oder in der nächsten woche
und ich hoffe auch sehr dass dann viele
schon vorausschauend anwenden und das
ganze umsetzen danke herr söder und auf
zdf heute steht das gespräch mit markus
söder ungeteilt und in voller länge
nachrichten von gundula gause aus china
kommt ein seltenes eingeständnis die
chinesischen corona impfstoffe hätten
eine niedrige wirksamkeit erklärte der
direktor des zentrums für
krankheitskontrolle in peking der staat
erwäge nun verschiedene impfstoffe zu
mischen um die wirksamkeit zu erhöhen
auch werde an der entwicklung neuer
impfstoffe gearbeitet auf basis der m
rna technologie die zb von biotech weise
genutzt wird
bundesarbeitsminister heil will das
geplante neue infektionsschutzgesetz
auch dafür nutzen
eine testpflicht für betriebe
durchzusetzen
mindestens einmal pro woche müsse jedes
unternehmen seinen mitarbeitern die
nicht im home office sind einen test
anbieten auch spd finanzminister und
kanzlerkandidat scholz sprach sich im
zdf dafür aus union und wirtschaft
lehnen eine testpflicht für betriebe
bislang ab die afd zieht mit der
forderung nach einer komplett anderen
corona politik in den
bundestagswahlkampf
in ihrem wahlprogramm fordert sie ein
ende des lockouts und die abschaffung
der masken pflicht außerdem fordert die
fdp die rückkehr zur wehrpflicht eine
abschaffung des rundfunkbeitrages den
austritt deutschlands aus der eu und ein
verbot von minaretten beim thema
migration bleibt die afg bei ihren
abgrenzungskurs die einwanderung soll
stark eingeschränkt und der
familiennachzug für flüchtlinge
abgeschafft werden zum 76 jahrestag der
befreiung der konzentrationslager
buchenwald und mittelbau-dora in
thüringen hat bundespräsident steinmeier
der opfer der nationalsozialisten
gedacht der bundespräsident mahnte die
erinnerung an die barbarischen
verbrechen wachzuhalten
in weimar weite nähe und thüringens
ministerpräsident ramelow ein
interaktives kunstwerk ein mit
botschaften von überlebenden zum lesen
und zum mitnehmen allein in das kz
buchenwald hatten die nazis etwa eine
viertelmillion menschen verschleppt mehr
als 56.000 wurden hier ermordet
manchmal braucht es wohl eine massive
krise damit man merkt was man hat in der
korona pandemie ist klar geworden wie
wertvoll und wie schlecht behandelt die
menschen sind die in pflegeberufen
arbeiten das ist nichts neues
auch wir haben darüber seit vielen
jahren immer wieder berichtet aber jetzt
erst fiel darauf ein grelles licht
das zdf widmet der arbeit und den
anliegen der pflegenden eine serie von
dokumentationen keine klugen reporter
kommentare die menschen selbst kommen zu
wort sozusagen mit herz und wie mein
name ist nadine bobos ich bin 41 jahre
alt und seit 16 jahren in dem die
krankenschwester
seit november bin ich im rahmen der
pandemie im cca eingesetzt das ist eine
spezielle klinik die eingerichtet wurde
für kobe patienten intensiv flüchtige
kuh wie patienten
guten morgen wenn sie mich verstehen
schließen sie mal die augen
wir reden mit jedem patienten egal wie
tief schlafend erscheint den patienten
habe ich vor zwei wochen tatsächlich in
einen spätdienst mit aufgenommen weil
der patient noch nicht beatmet der
überwachte 50 hat in der vorgeschichte
eine form des blutkrebs und hat sich
jetzt eben noch corona eingefangen und
hat tatsächlich dieses volle
krankheitsbild sowie 19 ausgebildet
jetzt ist es zwei wochen später an dem
patient ist immer noch beatmet was
natürlich nicht so erfreulich ist
andererseits konnte man auch kann man
auch sehen dass er sich stabilisiert hat
und wird sogar auf dem weg sind
die schlafmittel wieder ein bisschen zu
reduzieren so dass wir hoffentlich bald
den beatmungsschlauch entfernen können
wenn ich morgens meinen patienten
übernehmen
dann setze ich mir meistens zu tages
ziehen und zwar fällt es mir dadurch
leichter die aufgaben über den tag
besser zu priorisieren so dass ich mein
ziel nicht aus den augen verlieren
[Musik]
liebe auch lagerung ist ein ganz
spezielles manöver also wir drehen ja
den patienten tatsächlich um 180 grad um
seine eigene achse
das ist nicht so einfach also ich sag
mal bei einem recht normalgewichtigen
patienten brauchen wir dazu vier
pflegekräfte und ein arzt und ja umso
schwerer der patient umso mehr personal
braucht man dann auch weil man es
einfach da nicht mehr schafft diesen
menschen auf diese kissen zu heben
großes risiko sind immer die ganzen
schläuche die in dem patienten stecken
die ganzen zugänge katheter drainagen da
darf natürlich nichts raus reisen wir
dürfen ihn aber auch nicht darin
einwickeln es darf unter dem patienten
nachher nichts liegen
er würde sofort druckstellen davon
bekommen und ganz großes augenmerk wird
immer auf den warten schlauch natürlich
gelegt der arzt oder die ärztin stehen
am kopfende und halten den
beatmungsschlauch ist beim drehen weil
es immer ja die größte angst von allen
ist gestern habe ich mit einer freundin
telefoniert
und dann hat sie mir erzählt dass ihre
kollegin sich tatsächlich als crooner
leugner entpuppt hat und sie meine
freundin bekehren wollte und dann hat
mich meine freundin gefragt was sie so
leuten sagen soll
hatte ich ad hoc auch überhaupt keine
antwort gehört da muss jetzt darüber
nachdenken
und ich beschäftige mich jetzt schon den
ganzen tag und letztlich bin ich zu dem
ergebnis gekommen dass ich denke dass so
eine diskussion überhaupt gar keinen
sinn macht in meinen augen es ist eine
ganz persönliche meinung so diese
menschen fernab von jedem
wissenschaftlichen verständnis und jeder
realität
[Musik]
ein film der realität zeigt in der zdf
mediathek sind alle acht folgen der
doku-serie über nadine hofes und ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen ab sofort zu
finden herz und während wie gesagt ist
der hitler oder sie schalten nächste
woche täglich hallo deutschland und hier
nochmal nachricht zunächst zu fußball
bundesliga der erste fc köln verlor
gegen mainz 05 2 zu 3 köln damit auf dem
vorletzten platz der tabelle am abend
beurlaubte der fce-trainer gisdol
routinier friedhelm funkel soll wohl
übernehmen
die ebenfalls abstiegsbedrohten
rheinhessen kämpften sich auf rang 14
und im anderen sonntagsspiel gewann der
tabellenletzte schalke 04 gegen den fc
augsburg 1 zu 0 bei den ruder
europameisterschaften im italienischen
varese hat der erfolgsverwöhnte
deutschland achter einen bitteren
rückschlag kassiert platz vier hinter
großbritannien rumänien und den
niederlanden einer weltmeister oliver
zeidler holte dagegen die zweite em gold
medaille seiner karriere
der ingolstädter der seit dem wechsel
vom schwimmen zum rudern titel sammelt
will sich noch weiter steigern bis zu
olympia
ab dem 23 juli in tokio vor den
sommerspielen zeigt sich der deutsche
olympische sportbund besorgt über die
weltweit unterschiedliche handhabung von
dopingkontrollen während der pandemie
präsident hermann beklagt in der welt am
sonntag ein international größeres
ungleichgewicht der doping-kontrollen
als in den vorjahren
die nationale anti-doping-agentur nada
bestätigte dass dopingtests während
einer quarantäne ausgesetzt sein
sportler befürchten dass quarantäne
somit ein alibi für betrug bieten könnte
mit dem begriff preußen wird viel
verbunden ordnung und gehorsam
militärische präzision aufopferung eine
zuverlässige bürokratie und gerichte die
auch gegen fürsten furchtlos ihre
urteile sprechen
allein im namen des rechts preußen das
ist also nicht nur gutes aber eben auch
viel gutes ein ass bringt man mit
preußen
aber sicher nicht automatisch zusammen
lebensfreude und genuss dolce vita das
ist aber falsch
unser korrespondent in potsdam ist das
ins auge gefallen
nicola albrecht über erstaunliche und
keinesfalls zufällige parallele zwischen
palazzi und palmen flanieren und ein
wenig deutsche wieder auf der piazza
genießen
dessen italiensehnsucht angesichts
dieser bilder allzu groß wird zudem gibt
es eine gute nachricht sie kann gestellt
werden denn diese postkartenansichten
stammen gar nicht aus dem schönen aber
derzeit nur schwer erreichbaren rom
sie sind aus bella potsdam eigentlich
fühle ich mich wie in italien selbst das
wetter macht audi mit also da kann man
sich nicht beklagen oder man kommt sich
vor wie in einem palast aus einer
anderen rät man fühlt sich irgendwie
nicht wie in brandenburg versorgt die
anders urlaub und sehr schön
dass soviel italien in potsdam steckt
liegt daran dass bereits die preußischen
könige italiensehnsucht hatten erklärt
uns kunsthistorikern ortrud westheider
die verwandlung vom nüchternen soldaten
standort in ein architektonisches
schaustück begann im achtzehnten
jahrhundert die residenzstadt sollte
eine ideale stadt sein und da schaute
man eben auf den städtebau und auf die
einzelnen palazzi vor allen dingen in
rom
doch mit eigenen augen hört friedrich
der große rom nie gesehen seien strenger
vater hatte ihm die reise nach italien
verboten
stattdessen schickt er seine architekten
und ließ die schönsten bauwerke kopieren
und etwas bescheidener nachbauen
um dem elenden nest wir potsdam nannte
glanz zu verleihen
wenn man muss nur um schloss sanssouci
einmal herum gehen und von dort aus auf
den ruinen werk schauen dann weiß man
dass friedrich in seinem herzen ein
italiener war
heute lädt eine app zum virtuellen oder
auch realen spaziergang durch das ersatz
rom der preußischen könige ein
an 30 ausgewählten stationen zeigt sie
auf dem mobiltelefon original und
nachbau
[Musik]
an mancher stelle so täuschend echt dass
sogar waschechter italiener wie
christian otto und sein sohn hier fast
vergessen dass sie in potsdam lieben
da lese natürlich mehr aber wissen sie
was das diese diese großartige
architektur dieser wiese dieser flair
es ist schon sich schon was was was
imposantes es ist schon was
es ist da für das perfekte lebensgefühl
müsst ihr nur noch ein wenig mehr
italiener im potsdamer stecken meint er
ansonsten gelte immer noch der alte
spruch viele wege führen nach rom
in diesem fall auch der über potsdam um
hat heute übrigens nur zwei grad mehr
als potsdam eine woche kann nicht enden
ohne den blick des journals in die
nächsten heute von dominique lässt
musste
[Musik]
am montag wird die hannover messe
beginnen die weltgrößte industrieschau
corona bedingt dabei vollständig online
passend dazu auch das leitthema
industrielle transformation eröffnet
wird die digitale hannover messe von
bundeskanzlerin merkel für die muslime
in deutschland startet am dienstag der
fastenmonat ramadan
die gläubigen sind aufgerufen von
sonnenaufgang bis -untergang unter
anderem auf essen und trinken zu
verzichten der ramadan endet am 12
mai bundesinnenminister seehofer wird am
donnerstag die polizeiliche
kriminalstatistik 2020 vorstellen
schon jetzt ist bekannt die zahl der
wohnungseinbrüche ist mit 85.000 im
vergangenen jahr auf ein historisches
tief gefallen so die
versicherungswirtschaft deutschland wird
der korona totengedenken zuerst am
sonntag vormittag mit einem ökumenischen
gottesdienst in der
kaiser-wilhelm-gedächtniskirche
anschließend wird im konzerthaus am
gendarmenmarkt auf einladung des
bundespräsidenten dann die zentrale
gedenkveranstaltung stattfinden
und das wetter in der neuen woche bleibt
winterlich und zu kalt für die
jahreszeit morgen bleibt es im süden und
osten bedeckt und es gibt zeitweise
regen teilweise auch schnee bis in tiefe
lagen
sonst wechselnd bewölkt im nordwesten
mit regen schnee und graupelschauern bei
2 bis 10 grad ab dienstag gibt es nur
noch einzelne schnee oder regen schauer
wieder häufiger sonne und ähnlich
frische temperaturen
politisch wird es eine interessante
woche bettina schausten und heinz wolf
stehen dann hier für arbeit und
erkenntnisse der journal redaktion eine
gute zeit
bis bald
[Musik]